so I got a question from a reader on
YouTube who just bought a scansnap and
wanted to integrate it with Evernote and
was why noone is Evernote the best way
to manage your receipts this is the main
reason I bought my my scanner was
because it integrated with Evernote and
I could go paperless get rid of all my
receipts and now have no paper in my
office everything is digital and I use
either the scansnap or even now just the
the camera on my phone to be able to
take pictures and save it and Evernote
and have everything searchable so the
question here was just about the
scansnap I'm thinking about Evernote but
I don't know if I'll buy it not sure if
it's free scansnap came with fujitsu
rock to filer not sure with similar
Evernote what are your thoughts so
backing up for those of you who aren't
as familiar Evernote is a great way to
store all of your information anything
you want to keep on hand keep records
out so it's great for receipts that's
how I first started and then expanded to
use it for a whole bunch of different
options you'll find people are obsessed
with Evernote and use it for a lot of
different reasons I do too but for this
video we're just going to talk about
receipts like wait ready to use it is
with the Fujitsu scanner there's a
couple models of it this is the one that
I have here and you basically scan it in
it saves a digital image it goes to your
Evernote and the beautiful thing about
it is then you can search for it using
your computer so if you buy something at
Staples and you throw away the receipt
you could just type in staples and you
can find that receipt any time so it's
so much easier than having to go through
a shoebox full of data and the great
thing whatever not to is that everything
is online so you can find it from a web
browser you can find it from your mobile
device anywhere you can basically have
access any electronic device you can
find you receive so classic examples if
I had bought something at Staples I
could pull up the receipt on my iPad
from the store I could show it to them
they could scan it and give me a refund
for a product if I didn't have the
receipt anymore and I've done that so
it's a great way to manage your
information so the program that they
were talking about was called the rack -
filer I'm not really familiar with this
too much but it comes with Fujitsu if
you wanna you
I can't again talk too specifically
about it but the reason why I like
Evernote as a powerful software tool is
that it saves everything automatically
not just to your computer but also the
cloud and you can access it from any
device that you have that's connected to
Evernote so very powerful in terms of is
it free or not Evernote is free for up
to 60 megabytes so if you scan up to 60
megabytes of data you could do that
every month so 60 megabytes of new data
every month can be uploaded for free to
Evernote and their servers and when I
was just scanning receipts that's all I
use it was the free version I never
really went past my 16 megabytes if
you're scanning in mostly black and
white stuff and it's receipts you're not
really going to go past the limit it's
when you get into color documents or
really high-resolution stuff pictures
that you want to save that can start to
chew up your your limits a little bit
more the main reason why I went pro was
if you want mobile access to your files
offline so I use Evernote a lot for
travel and I'll make notes of every city
I'm going to and what I'm gonna do in
each city and I need access to that
locally so I don't want to connect to
the internet to be able to get those
files and so to do that you have to pay
the premium or business version and that
starts at five dollars a month so the
premium version if you really want to do
it is five dollars a month or forty five
bucks for the year this gives you one
gigabyte per month and if you go up the
business that's two gigabytes of data
per month and you get the offline access
so I'm on the premium plan now but only
because I use it for reasons outside of
business receipts if you're on the wrist
if you're just using for receipts the
easiest way to get started is just a
free plan and it helps you test test it
out see if you like it see if you're
getting value from it and if then you
want to invest more into it you can but
you probably wouldn't need to if you
just using it for receipts so I want to
click over to Evernote quickly so this
is my Evernote I have a ton of notebooks
these are my receipts so I have almost
4,000 notes and anytime I buy something
or use my my credit card I'll pop it in
here and it'll save a picture this is
what it'll look like if
through your scansnap and evernote and
you can see the receipt so I don't even
know what this is that I bought but it
cost me $24 so there we go so about it
Sharon garden and if I ever needed to
you know print this off I could print it
off again and use it for accounting
purposes if I wanted to more recently I
haven't even been using the scans app
I've just been taking pictures using my
camera phone
it's a pendant when I'm buying so this
Costco so this has to be sorted but you
know so I bought a hotdog at Costco and
I can scan it in here and this will come
up with a full text search I'm using
both but I tend to lean more towards the
camera just because it's a lot easier
but if you need to high quality then it
you can pull it up from your scansnap
but the beautiful thing about this and
if you're looking at any other solution
you want to make sure this ability is
here is to do a search so if say I
bought something at Staples I can pull
up I could just type staples and they'll
pull up something here so this is how a
picture that I took where's this a
picture that I took of a receipt and it
can see that I've bought it from Staples
if ever need to find this you can see
you know what I bought here are some
Drive some scissors packing tape and it
highlights the word so it's found that
for me automatically I can go on and
here's another one that I bought some
paper and it just pulls it from staples
again so the beautiful thing about this
is you could throw away all your
receipts your contract your documents
anything that that is just take it up
space and clutter and it's hard to find
when you really need it it scans it in
it saves it as full-text PDF it saves it
locally to your computer and online so
you can find it from any of your devices
and whenever you need to find it you
just type in the key word up here and it
will pull it up and from here I can load
it up as a PDF to email it if I want to
I could print it off I can show it on my
iPad if I need to go into the store and
ask for a refund
so just basically quick access to all
the information you need just by doing a
quick search so that's why I love using
Evernote and hopefully that answers the
question vs bunny 1 if you have any
other questions let me know and I would
be
happy to do another video for you guys
thank you take care